one of my favorite promotions to run to
an audience is a gift card play the way
the gift card play works is simple you
say hey I've got these 200 gift cards
and you want the gift card price to be
about what one month of service is or
one kind of core element of your service
you sell those for 95 off and you say
I'm going to limit to you to two per
person all right so this is key you have
a limit to the amount of gift cards
somebody can buy and you do it for a
very defined periods seven days three
days 48 Hours you sell a ton of these
and what they have to do is register the
person who they're giving the gift card
to and so what happens is you end up
getting paid to get leads to sell your
core thing to and so the people get
Goodwill because the friend they're
giving the card to doesn't know that
they paid five dollars for a 200 gift
card and so they get the gift they're
happy about it you get the lead you're
happy about it and you get paid to get
to do this all together it's a wonderful
play I highly recommend